こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん会社に入ってますでしょうか私今年の目標が葉を全部
線ずに保つっていう目標があるんですけどもそのために雑魚と塩めっちゃくちゃ歯医者
行きまくってるんですけどもう週一で行って
もう3週間ぐらい入ってなかった時期もあったんですけど基本的に週1で廃車に急にし
てましてむしろまともなをしてるしあのがいなくてないって言ったことなんで
恥ずかしいことにそれはいいんだなこれは授業中でして今日も花が配されるんですけど
もうこう思ったんですよ愛車の治療2ってもうならやることになってずっとこうやって
出てるだけじゃないですか
あるもったいないですかどうせだったらあの時間を何か良い
有効活用できないかということであの風景今やらなきゃいけないこととしては動画編集
があるんですよでパソコンカタカタしなきゃいけないということで入っちゃってでも
もう目止めるから
で飛べる状況でで種子を買って怒ったときにこれがあればできるのではないかなと思い
ました
こちら水動画で使ったわかるんですけどもメガネとしてつけると見える角度がこうやっ
て変わる
何に今文化パテつけるとましたが見えるようになります今だったらこの手が見えてる
わけですこれ
てが見えるでしょそうこれつけるとましたが見えるようになるんですよ
さては僕
天才かつまりですね歯医者さんで治療しているてくれて人が横にあるんですよ横になっ
ている僕に入ってこの眼鏡をかけると本支店がこういう人に変わるんで高校でパパボン
こうやっておいておくと敗者の授業を受けながらでも演習がはかどるのではないかと
いうことでこれうまくいったら画期的ですよお仕事でパソコン度が忙しい方愛車いき
ながら仕事がはかどるかも知れませ
よってけどこれやりたいんですけども本当にできるかどうかっていうのを歯医者の許可
を取らないといけないと思うんで
実際にできるかどうか聞いてみた所委員長さんありがとうございます評価をいただき
ましたてる早速歯医者で治療を受けながら編集していこうと思いますちょちょっと
まっすぐに使わない代わりにちょっぴりだけ言いたいみたいなこと聞いてたんでまぁ
そこさえ耐えればきっと編集ちょっとできるでしょ
出会いかーっ
me
はぁ
ハセオーデータ
多分つ両町の編集ができるんじゃねーかという
マスタースカみたいですうわぁはい当然製品
まず最初に
上の歯の肌を守りたいんだぜを7したら大
上仲方が記されている
[音楽]
目線を作ります
バッツへ滑りますね
これで完備講演会を兼ねる
これで完了お待ちくださいこれ
me
[音楽]
ん
以下をほしいですかいいです
このあとでぜんぶあーげーずに会いましょうです
me
goo
[音楽]
ステータスはしません
ね
見ながら作業したい人もいるみたいです
wh
tee
dnano
too far
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
tar
goo
[音楽]
web
voodoo
高機能を持っています
ていません
me
はいその時に上の歯の治療ミス見えない
アフランくださいと言うとはい1週間ぐらい目2きます
あっすぐなきゃいけどはいというわけで敗者の通常が終わったんですけども次から普通
に受けよう
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ